welche farbe hat dieser hintergrund blau
grün grau grün türkis petrol freude
durch mein lieber ein ziel setzt euch
die antwort gibt sehr viel tiefer als
eure display einstellungen macht euch
bereit für ein bisschen okay wir müssen
reden über diese farbe aber bevor wir
das können müssen wir erstmal über diese
farbe reden das ist gelb richtig wichtig
nur was sie hier seht ist eigentlich gar
kein richtiges gelb das geld ist nur in
eurem kopf also was ich hier sehe ist
echtes geld das heißt echtes gelbes
licht licht ist elektromagnetische
strahlung die gibt es in allen möglichen
wellenlängen röntgenstrahlen radiowellen
uv-strahlen und auf diesen breiten
spektrum der elektromagnetischen
strahlung gibt es einen kleinen bereich
wo wir die strahlung sehen können in
form von farben es für uns sichtbare
licht liegt in einem wellenlängenbereich
zwischen 400 und 700 80 nanometer jede
farbe hat eine bestimmte wellenlänge rot
ist länger wähle ich violet ist kürzer
wellig und gelbes zwischendrin mit einer
wellenlänge von etwa 570 nanometern je
nach gelb ton so das tageslicht oder
auch das licht hier aus meinen
scheinwerfern ist aber weiß hier sind
alle wellenlängen drin wie kriegt man
jetzt auch so einen breiten weißen
lichts eine bestimmte farbe das heißt
eine bestimmte wellenlänge das nicht auf
meiner lampe trifft jetzt auf diesen
hintergrund der absorbiert das legt das
heißt er verschluckt es bis auf eine
wellenlänge nämlich die gelbe linie
reflektiert und die das gelbe licht
trifft jetzt in meinem auge auf meine
netzhaut auf der netzhaut besitzen licht
empfehlen
reflektoren einmal die stäbchen die sind
für hell und dunkel zuständig und die
zapfen die sind für farben zuständig wie
menschen sind so genannte trikot marten
das bedeutet wir haben drei verschiedene
rezeptoren auf der netzhaut die
verschiedene wellenlängen absorbieren
können blaue rezeptoren grün rezeptoren
und rot rezeptoren benannt nach der
wellenlänge wie sie am besten
absolvieren können er ist licht mit 570
nanometern fällt in den absorptions
bereich sowohl des grünen rezeptors als
auch des road rezeptors das gericht wird
auf meine netzhaut also sowohl von den
grünen rezeptoren als auch von den rot
rezeptoren absorbiert und die gehen dann
das signal gelb an mein gehirn weiter
aber sobald ich mich an den rechner
setzen und dieses video schneide ist
dieses geld kein echtes geld mehr für
euch ist das auch kein echtes geld mehr
in eure augen fällt kein gelbes licht
obwohl die hier verschiedene farben
sieht hat euer bildschirme wirklichkeit
nur drei verschiedene farben rot grün
und blau rgb würden wir jetzt die extrem
rein zoomen dann würdet ihr sehen dass
das geld was ihr gerade seht in
wirklichkeit nur eine mischung aus rot
und grün
das ist insofern komisch weil sich
physikalisch rotes und grünes licht
nicht mischen können um eine neue farbe
zu ergeben den rotes und grünes licht
bedeuten zwei verschiedene wellenlängen
und strahlen mit verschiedener
wellenlängen können nicht physikalisch
miteinander interagieren ihr könnt also
nicht einfach nur 600 nanometer
wellenlänge auf eine 400 nanometer
wellenlänge strahlen und die vermischen
sich es kommt 500 nanometer raus das
funktioniert nicht wie ihr gerade das
geld trifft kein gelbes licht auf eure
netzhaut stattdessen fällt rotes und
grünes licht gleichzeitig in eure augen
für eure farb rezeptoren ist es dasselbe
in grün und rot genau wie bei mir werden
bei euch die rot und grün rezeptoren
beide aktiviert euer gehirn macht es
keinen unterschied farbe hat also eine
objektive physikalische komponente eine
äußere komponenten nämlich die
wellenlänge und eine subjektive innere
komponente nämlich die wahrnehmung im
kopf genau das behalten wir mal im kopf
während ich weiter erzählt denn ihr
kriegt gleich ein richtiges ich muss mir
erst ein kleines bisschen ausholen
passau menschen die farbenblind sind
haben in den meisten fällen eine
sogenannte rot grün schwäche
korrekterweise müsste man sagen farben
fehlsichtig tatsächlich gibt es menschen
die gar keine farben sehen können also
die welt in schwarz weiß sie das aber er
selbst menschen mit rot grün schwäche
erkennen auf solchen bildern keine
zahlen sondern nur punkte ein anderer
text ist der sogenannte fan zu erzählen
hand verwischen test hier muss man
verschiedene farbtöne entlang einer
reihe so anordnen dass ein möglichst
glatter pub gradient entsteht
hiermit kann man etwas genauer bestimmen
welche art von fehlsichtigkeit genau
vorliegt die blaue rezeptoren sind eher
selten betroffen meistens sind es
entweder die rot oder grün rezeptoren
die die falsche wellenlänge absorbieren
das liegt wenn man so will an defekten
ich sag mal rot rezeptor proteinen oder
grün rezeptor proteinen und die gene
diese proteine bilden während vererbt
rezessiv über das x-chromosom deswegen
sind bei farbenblindheit fast immer nur
männer betroffen da sie nur ein
x-chromosom haben sind sie betroffen
sobald dieses chromosom das
entsprechende gen mit sich bringt bei
frauen die zwei x-chromosomen haben
müssten schon beide x-chromosomen
betroffen sein damit sich das auswirkt
deswegen sind bei frauen unter 1 prozent
betroffen bei männern ist es etwa jeder
zwölfte gleich gibt es aber bei teilung
dazu muss man sich lediglich ein
ein virus ins auge spritzen klingt
komisch ist aber so nennt sich
gentherapie dadurch kann man über einen
virus das richtige gehen ins auge rein
schleusen das dann auch die richtigen
rezepte proteine bildet totenkopfaffen
wurde das sogar schon gemacht die
männlichen totenkopfäffchen haben
nämlich alle einen defekten roth rezepte
was sie zu perfekten versuchs modellen
für eine rot grün schwäche macht die
affen wurden vor einem touchscreen
gesetze waren graue kreise drauf und
immer mal wieder erschienen farbflecken
und die sollten sie dann an bzw
habt ihr den ich so an getippt hatte
immer so mit ihrem kopf also immer wenn
die erfolgreich den farbfleck
identifizieren konnten bekam sie als
belohnung traumhaft nur wenn der fleck
roth war konnten wir dir nicht erkennen
und haben sie nicht darauf reagiert der
neurologin janes spritzte jetzt einige
affen ein virus der sie mit rot rezeptor
dna infizierte und 20 wochen später
fingen die affen an die roten flecken zu
erkennen sie wurden von ihrer fahrt
blindheit geheilt aber doch gibt es
diese therapie nicht das fehlen noch die
klinischen studien an menschen so aber
jetzt kommt ich muss mein hintergrund
wechseln aus dramaturgischen gründen
werden die gene die für das farbsehen
verantwortlich sind über das x-chromosom
vererbt werden und frauen zwei davon
haben gibt es dann frauen mit einer
super kalorischen kurz gesagt
wahrscheinlich schon
man vermutet dass 23 prozent aller
frauen kendra kroaten sind das heißt
dass sie nicht drei sondern vier
verschiedene faktoren in ihrem auge
haben sie haben einen weiteren
farbkonzepte mit einer maximalen
absorption zwischen rot und grün also
eine art gelb rezeptor nur eine rezeptur
mehr würde den riesigen unterschied
machen ein mensch kann ungefähr eine
million verschiedene farbtöne sehen
ein truck roman könnte ungefähr 100
millionen verschiedene farben sehen so
man kann anhand der dna also mit einem
bluttest sehen ob eine frau ein täter
chromat ist oder nicht
janes begann diese frauen zu suchen
zusammen mit der neurologin gable jordan
fanta insgesamt neun frauen mit petra
chromat dna er entwickelte sogar einen
kanadischen test mit gelbem licht es
zwei verschiedene gelbtöne die für uns
ununterscheidbar sind wie aber eint
extra chromat mit gelb rezeptor
unterscheiden können sollte und sie
sagen keinen unterschied
lediglich eine frau erkannte den
unterschied heißt dass jetzt die frauen
hatten doch kein 4 rezeptor nicht
unbedingt denn jetzt freunde der sonne
wird ist richtig ich könnte ein täter
chromat sein und nichts davon mir denn
wir erinnern uns objektive komponenten
subjektive du nicht die wahrnehmung
immer diese innere komponente also die
wahrnehmung des gehirns spielt eine
unglaublich große rolle bestes beispiel
dafür
die tatsache dass wir menschen lange
kein blau sehen konnten
es gab eine zeit da konnten wir kein
blau sehen also wir hatten früher kein
blau rezepte unserer netzhaut war
genauso wie heute wir haben es nur nicht
gecheckt fast 1858 machte der engländer
william gladstone eine seltsame
entdeckung als ein großer fan
altgriechischer literatur und der
vergötterte romer umso mehr störte es
ihn dass rom er anscheinend keine ahnung
von farben hatte in der odyssee war zum
beispiel die rede von weide rote meer
oder violetten schafen und gladstone
tochter sich was stimmt nicht mehr
war das ein stilistisches mittel oder
war der mann vielleicht farbenblind es
hatten haben sich gestern die odyssee
vor und schaute wie oft welche farbe
vorkommt das ergebnis etwa 200 mal das
wort spaß und hundert mal weiß ca 15 mal
rot gelb und grün jeweils weniger als 10
und 1 keinen einziges mal blau in
sämtlichen kulturen und sprachen
tauchten als erste farbwerte schwarz und
weiß auf danach tauchte irgendwann das
wort roth auf dann ist es von sprache
und kultur bisschen verschiedenen komma
grün oder erst gelb aber viermal relativ
spät erst blau geben hat sich also
relativ spät dass gedanken gemacht um
das wort blau
aber wenn wir doch schon immer den
blauen rezepte auf unsere netzhaut
hatten müssen wir doch auch schon immer
blau gesehen haben aber wie kein wort
dafür haben heißt doch nicht dass wir es
nicht gesehen haben doch noch mal drüber
nach sprache entsteht ja aus einer
gewissen notwendigkeit heraus
verschiedene farben müssen eine
bedeutung haben irgendeine relevanz
haben damit die notwendigkeit entsteht
sie zu benennen und sie zu unterscheiden
das schwarz und weiß die ersten fahrt
wörter waren ist logisch dem sie
bezeichnet dunkel und hell danach kam
das wort rot rot wie blut rot wie manche
bären in der natur oder irgendwelche
waren farben von tieren blau ist in der
natur unglaublich selten um das wenige
blau dass wir der natur sehen
entsteht auch ganz anders als alle
anderen farben farben entstehen
normalerweise durch pigmente also konnte
blätter entstehen durch chlorophyll
meine haare hautfarbe sind melanie ne
und für - und gefärbt durch carotinoide
der blaue morpho videos schmetterling
übrigens auch aus ihlow tier helbig hat
keine blauen pigmente bei pigmenten wird
das licht absorbiert also geschluckt bis
auf eine wellenlänge nämlich die
entsprechende farbe die den reflektiert
wird am schmetterlingsflügel haben wir
aber kein blaues pigment sondern eine
feine mikrowellen struktur die
absorbiert das licht zwar nichts aber
alle wellenlängen die nicht blau sind
werden so reflektiert das sieht man sagt
destruktiv interferieren was bedeutet
sie kennt sich aus im mikrostruktur
liegt also in genau der richtigen
größenordnung für die blaue wellenlänge
dasselbe gilt auch für blau in
vogelfedern und selbst blaue augen
beruhten nicht auf blauen pigmenten
sondern auf eine entsprechende
mikrostruktur es gibt so gut wie keine
natürlichen blaupigmente und selbst
blaubär oder so heidelbeeren sind genau
genommen violett und nicht blau und
nicht nur die natur tut sich schwer
blaupigmente herzustellen auch die
menschen haben eine zeitlang gebraucht
bis sie selbst blaupigmente und blaue
farben selber herstellen konnten um zum
beispiel t-shirts zu bedrucken was will
ich damit sagen weil die farbe blau in
der natur so selten ist entstand die
notwendigkeit für ein wort blau erst mit
der eigenen herstellung von blauen
farben okay aber jetzt fragt ihr euch
natürlich was ist mit dem fucking himmel
da haben wir doch genau so weit das auge
reicht oder rot denn ich brauche eure
volle aufmerksamkeit jetzt kommt der
richtige
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass wir
menschen denen himmel nicht als blaue
wahrgenommen haben bevor wir ein wort
für blaue hatten pass physikalisch
gesehen konnten wir auch schon immer
sehen unsere blaue rezeptoren haben
diese farbe schon immer absorbiert wir
haben nichts davon gemerkt schaut man
durch alte literatur findet man zb die
bezeichnung grüner hinwil und in einigen
sprachen gibt es heute noch keine
sprachliche differenzierung zwischen
grün und blau in meiner muttersprache
vietnamesisch ist es ähnlich blau und
grün ist da dasselbe wort nämlich muss
sein kann differenzieren indem man sagt
maus an la was so viel heißt wie das
rauschen der blätter so grün oder im
ausland
das glaub ich ist das system ist also
blau der psychologe james david auf
wollte es genauer wissen und besuchte
den himba stammt in namibia in deren
sprache ist kein wort für blau gibt er
zeige den menschen dieses bild wo der
eine kasten offensichtlich blau ist
während alles andere grün ist die
menschen hatten tatsächlich probleme den
andersfarbigen kasten zu identifizieren
dafür hat der nebenbei starben mehrere
sprachliche differenzierungen für die
farbe grün also jetzt könnt ihr mal
selber schauen welche dieser kästchen
ist ein anderer grünton als die anderen
ich sehe da überhaupt kein unterschied
aber tatsächlich ist dieses kästchen
anders als die anderen für die menschen
in stams war das einfacher als die erste
übung also nochmal alle menschen haben
die gleichen farb rezeptoren im auge
aber unsere sprache kann unsere
farbwahrnehmung in manchen fällen
überhaupt erst befähigen nur was sehen
die menschen des hirnstamms jetzt wenn
sie in einen blauen himmel schauen
vielleicht sowas vielleicht auch nicht
der linguist guy deutscher hat auf dem
regele podcast dazu eine sehr
interessante anekdote erzählt er hat
eine kleine tochter und er hat ihr
irgendwann ganz normal die farben
beigebracht wie man einem kind eben die
farben beibringt nur hat er eine kleine
info verschwiegen nämlich dass der
himmel blau ist um zu sehen ob sie
vielleicht schon selber drauf kommt wir
sind sogar das macht mir in meinem kind
dann später auch also seine tochter
lernte ganz normal was die farbe blau
ist also er hätte jetzt hier aufgezeigt
was ist das eine farbe
mit gesagt blau so immer wenn sie jetzt
draußen unterwegs waren und der himmel
blau war zeigte er auf den himmel und
fragte und was für eine farbe ist dass
seine tochter war anfangs einfach nur
irritiert hätte ich doch gar nichts
schien so als würde sie da gar nichts
gesehen passt wohl fühlt times and white
einen finally after months of momence
sie verblüffte first time mit all diesem
hintergrundwissen hätten wir uns also
wieder diesem hintergrund sei dass
menschen sich über verschiedene blau
grün töne besonders uneinig sind in der
sprachlichen bezeichnung ist ein
häufiges phänomen natürlich die dieses
video mit all seinen farben auf jedem
screen je nach farbkorrektur ein kleines
bisschen anders aus aber selbst wenn ihr
jetzt alle hier wird und wir würden
gemeinsam diesen hintergrund anschauen
wer ich mir sicher werden wir uns
trotzdem uneinig über die bezeichnung
dieser farbe also ich sehe hier schon
grünstich aber müsste ich mich jetzt
entscheiden zwischen blau und grün würde
ich das auf jeden fall als blau
bezeichnet er melanie unsere grafikerin
würde dass er als grün bezeichnen oder
muss es jetzt nicht heißen dass melanie
und ich die farben verschieden sehen
vielleicht haben wir lediglich
verschiedene sprachliche definition das
heißt aber auch wie eine farbe aussieht
ist überhaupt nicht objektiv sondern
alles hier drin ich kann nicht wissen ob
dein roth genauso aussieht in deinem
kopf wie maine road es ist absolut
möglich das was für mich roth ist in
meiner wahrnehmung in deinem kopf
aussieht wie mein blaues ist absolut
möglich dass meine welt und deine welt
farblich völlig verschieden aussehen
hier drin es gibt keine möglichkeit das
herauszufinden wie
seid ihr lasst es mich wissen und wir
sehen uns in der entkam so leute zu dem
zeitpunkt wo ich das hier aufnehmen
haben die aktuell 99 1814 abonnenten wir
sind so nah dran an den 100000 klar weil
wir schon sogar dran sind könnte ich
mich auch einfach jetzt schon freuen
beziehungsweise ich freue mich schon die
ganze zeit also sowieso freue ich mich
über diesen kanal aber ich freue mich in
den letzten monaten besonders darüber
wie stark wir wachsen aber ich habe ja
auch erst im letzten video erklärt dass
wir menschen gerne runde zahlen mögen
und deswegen dass dieser meilenstein
100000 natürlich der wie soll ich sagen
ich freudig allzu langer zeit letztes
jahr hätte ich noch geld darauf gewettet
dass ich niemals in den jede 100000
komme ich hoffe dass wenn ihr dieses
video seht wenigen daten zu geknackt
haben aber ich möchte mich jetzt nicht
im voraus freuen
ich werde das ganze sicher den zeit-
oder feiern wenn ihr mir da folgen wollt
gerne ansonsten überlege ich mir
vielleicht etwas für nächste woche wir
sehen uns also nächsten sommers sagt
freunde der sonne bis dahin bleibt
sicher